[موسيقى]
تتكون الطبقه الخارجيه للارض المعروفه
باسم الغلاف الصخري من عدد من الصفائح
التكتونيه الكبيره او الحواف تتحرك لتكون
اما متباعده عن بعضها او مستضمه او منزلقه
عبر حدودها ما يجعل الزلازل مدمره وجود
تحركات عنيفه وقويه في الصفائح التكتونيه
وتتسبب هذه القوه في هزات ارضيه تبعتها
تختلف حسب اختلاف قوه التصادم ولان تركيا
تقع بين لوحين متصادمين هما لوح شمال
افريقيا ولوح منطقه اوراسيا فالزلازل تحدث
عاده عند تقابل هذين اللوحين وتحركيهما
ويسمى الاصطدام عمليه الاندساس على مر
الازمنه تشكلت احزمه زلزاليه ابرزها
واشهرها الحزم الناري ويمتد على طول 40
الف كيلو متر من التشيلي الى المكسيك
مرورا بالساحل الغربي للولايات المتحده
الى الاجزاء الجنوبيه من الاسكا ثم يمتد
ليشمل اليابان والفلبين وغينيا الجديده و
يشبه حدوه حصان ويسمى حزم النار لانه يضم
اكثر من 450 بركانا ويحدث فيه نحو 80% من
زلازل الارض الاعنف في العالم بينها زلزال
تشيلي الكبير عام 60 من القرن الماضي
الحزام الاخر هو الحزام الالبي ويقع في
منطقه تمتد لاكثر من 15 الف كيلو متر من
جاوا واوسو في اندونيسيا نحو المحيط
الاطلسي ويعبر جبال الهيمالايا وجبال
ايران والقوقاز والانادول والبحر الابيض
المتوسط في هذا الحزام تقع نحو 17% من
اكبر الزلازل في العالم وشهد اكثر الزلازل
تدميرا مثل زلزال باكستان عام 2005 وزلزال
اندونيسيا المدمر عام 2004
من ابرز الدول المهدده بالزلازل في هذا
الحزام كل من تركيا والهند وكازاخستان
ودول جنوب اوروبا المطله على البحر الابيض
المتوسط ودول الشرق الاوسط مثل سوريا
ولبنان ودول شمال افريقيا ومصر الحزام
الثالث هو حزام منتصف الاطلسي ويمثل منطقه
التقاء الصفائح القاريه ويحدث في عمق
المحيط وبعيدا عن الاماكن الحضريه مسؤول
عن ثلاثه في المئه فقط من الزلازل الكبيره
اذ ان اغلبها صغيره لكن ايسلندا كمثال
تعرضت لزلازل كبيره بلغت درجتها نحو سبع
درجات يتوقع الخبراء تكرار الزلازل في
مناطق اخرى لانها تقع ضمن حزام زلزالي على
غرار تركيا ويطالبون بالاستفاده من تجارب
دول كاليابان ومن التكنولوجيا الحديثه في
بناء المباني وتصميم الطرق والمرافق
العامه لتناسب الطبيعه الجيولوجيه
[موسيقى]